speaking of um getting taken out
adrian's kickback dude what a what a
world
149 people arrested 149 people arrested
so this all happened from tick tock
right and how did the meme even start
how does any [ __ ] meme start because
the kid adrian like posted a
like an actual ad to his cake back but
people probably do that all every day
all day
i think it was like the text and all
that it just seemed
like something someone would make if
they were 40
okay and to be 16 i think it was so
polarizing that
so many young kids were like there's no
way you
made that can i see the flyer uh if we
have a shot of it
i want to see that so then people were
flying into town for it
like so this thing went viral he posted
this he said hey i'm having a kickback
or whatever and it went totally viral a
parade of beamers
drove like some absurd amount of miles
there's like 200 cars like a full car
club
drove to adrian's kickback it made me
want to leave hawaii
to go to the kickback i'm like i need to
i know i saw the
all the footage of people like lighting
fireworks off on the street and stuff
like that i was like this seems kind of
sick
i you know
i i know the nelk boys were looking at
that being like these [ __ ]
yeah yeah we gotta do it bigger than
them
gotta do it bigger than adrian yeah all
right guys
meet up in times square this weekend
yeah that's it was you know they
they rolled out like uh like
riot squads man to shut these kids down
all right who who is this now everything
that happened at the adrian kickback
let's see this
huntington beach too yeah such a perfect
place for this to go down
yeah most definitely oh no pause the
pause deposit pause
it pause it pause deposit web copywriter
music
it's okay it's all right no worries
adrian had a kickback
we're aware yeah
last two times i've been to huntington
beach there was a trump rally both times
one of them was after he got after he
didn't get elected
nice yeah yeah they love trump down
there
oh they do yeah orange county yeah the
big big orange county [ __ ] with trump
yeah they do
you know like i think it's manhattan
beach there's like
uh i didn't realize this there's like a
it's like a memorial stone i feel for
like a black-owned hotel
and the family that owned it just
literally just got ran out of town
what yeah in manhattan beach yeah
there's a lot of that
weird like you know i and i guess
huntington
before everything supposedly it was like
a
like a white supremacy hangout spot like
like biker gangs would chill down oh
yeah yeah okay that makes sense and so
yeah it's just like it's it's it's so
weird because it's such a nice place and
then
when you like dig into like some of the
roots you're like oh that's
uncomfortable
yeah that's really shitty yeah it's just
further you
get out of l.a oh yeah you get more
trump flags you start seeing everything
yeah
weirdo pockets man oh yeah
anyway you know you know they're they're
going crazy
for the no mask [ __ ] now like yeah
[ __ ]
i'm i'm stoked too man june 15th june
15th they said no
uh capacity things anymore no masks
you just can't celebrate too early
because then people get the wrong idea
about you yeah that's true
no math [ __ ] yeah no man [ __ ] yeah no
mess well wait not like that man
oh [ __ ] i thought she was never mind
voucher more like fraud jeez nice
anyways let's not even do that it's
crazy how
you get deleted from twitter and you
just get like erased
what do you mean i mean you know trump
got forcibly
logged off yeah you don't read his press
releases that he really no i'm not
subscribed dude
but you know like i had like a burner
email that i had on my instagram for a
while and just you know
big ups to everyone who may sort of sign
me up for all trump related things
15 times the four times i've checked
that thing it's just like
thank you for signing up for the trump
campaign i'm like cool
i'm gonna i'm gonna delete my twitter
and start putting out updates through
press releases through a blog through a
blog
take it old school man yeah exactly see
me at livejournal.com
cody thinks hey guys wanna just wanted
to update you guys on my thoughts on
crypto
no dude not again
wait new main quitting social media no
way
uh is he quitting no it was it was like
a bait video
is this him i guess this is my first
youtube video
and probably like four or five years if
you don't know who i am my name is kane
trujillo
and um new maine on tick tock [ __ ] any
um
oh yeah music [ __ ] yeah who who even
cares it's like
at the end he's like i'm not quitting
i'm never going away
[Laughter]
really yeah did he ever address any of
the things that people were saying
no like i'm wondering what his thoughts
are
you you know that he it's just like the
ultimate double down he doesn't like
really feel any but you got to think if
every person on the internet is like
this is [ __ ] up
some people can just roll with that yeah
i guess especially gen z they don't give
a [ __ ]
nah they don't they've been dealing with
negative comments they're that's what i
noticed man it's so
much bullying happens on tick tock kids
don't care at all
nah nah they don't they got thick skin
yeah yeah it's like uh
you adventure to say that
some call of duty players would be
hard-pressed to be
yeah put together in the tick-tock
environment yeah
it's like because because the bullying
on tick-tock is it's just wildly
specific
like someone will sit there and watch
your tick tock six seven times to be
like
why is your left ear bigger yeah yeah
exactly
yeah no it's not yeah yeah it is bro
look at the lighting look in the mirror
yeah oh it's not bigger post a picture
of yourself right now yeah
a thousand comments ah big gear and then
every tick tock after that
big what's up big ear hey can you hear
me what's up dumbo
sorry you didn't catch me when you step
on the left side yeah
and then and then you know when like
spacex rocket successfully crashes
through
the stratosphere creating a sonic boom
there's people tagging him in that [ __ ]
you heard that [ __ ] huh
i bet your left ear caught that huh big
ear [ __ ] your grandma uses you
for a [ __ ] cable tv huh yeah
so yeah yeah definitely uh
the kids they just don't give a [ __ ]
that's like the i think the first thing
when you use tick tock you're like oh
they talk [ __ ] on here
oh yeah oh yeah with the amount that
like body positivity and stuff like that
is increasing bullying is also
increasingly yeah
yeah it's crazy i think adults think
that tick tock is like a safer platform
i i think it's the you see some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] on that who is thinking that
like even even the ability to stitch
and to react to people's stuff like you
know what i'm saying yeah i mean like i
do that i don't take talk but i mean say
like people
brutalize that oh yeah definitely seen
some mean ones
yeah it's crazy to just be like
consuming that [ __ ] all day yeah
you know you know like a lot of these
kids just eating that out laughing like
a man
like hell yeah make fun of people get
them yeah
yeah i don't think new man cares i think
he likes it i think he likes the
attention
yeah that's just that you know i'm not
gonna
diagnose anybody but there's some people
who thrive on
any attention yeah
you